um
so the petition is on freeross.org and
people can sign it
and uh how many people are you guys do
you guys need to get to make
something happen you know there is no
magic number
um 360 000 is a pretty big number
um basically i've been using it as a pr
tool in terms of if i talk to a
legislator and i go
hey check out the petition this is 360
000 people who
and they go whoa it's a movement this
isn't just one guy
some guy it's a movement and it has
become a movement
and so it's it's really to show um
it's so it's not like oh it reaches this
magic number and he's out no
that doesn't work i wish it did we'd be
but um
it does help and it shows backing and it
gives
you know emphasis to this and i think
you know it's
it's helpful because really it helps me
get people to support our thing knowing
they know
all these people are behind it and
there's lots of others i mean the
libertarian party
came out officially asking for clemency
for ross
um many leaders if you go on our way
our website there's a page called
widespread support
it's impressive there are a lot of
people speaking out for ross
just recently congressman thomas massey
tweeted it's time to free ross and
snowden and assange but
you know just free ross albrecht um and
other people in politics as well as in
the tech sector as well as in the
cryptocurrency world you know there's
all kinds of people
and just politics and just people who
are well known
um have come out for ross and on both
sides of the aisle it's not just
libertarians
it's it's um you know people on the left
people on the right
all can see that this is wrong
that this sentence puts everyone in
peril
if they can do it to him they can do it
to to other people it's not just
him you know it matters it impacts the
um
precedent that they can use to cage more
people
for longer well i can't thank you enough
for doing this
i i really appreciate you taking the
time to share with with our audience
your story and and uh
i'm super grateful for you doing this um
i'm grateful to you for
giving me voice i'll put the links in
the description for people to visit
freeross.org
um is there anything else i should link
down below for people
to go find more information or take
action
we've got the link to the petition and i
i linked to the website and then the
link to that um
documented information that is really
quite riveting
and you know you can listen to it as a
podcast or watch it as kind of a
little video or um just read it and i
recommend it if you're at all interested
in the case it's
it's documented so it's all based on the
public record i wish i had
the whole thing but much of the uh
evidence is still sealed
and encrypted and that's another
question why is the government
continuing to hide
this what's in this case if it's done
and they got their man
why aren't and they did it all according
to the book why is
the information sealed but it is
undisclosed
so i but even just working from the
public record it's shocking
it's a real insight into how uh the
whole thing works
and who is involved and we have you know
all kinds of chara
cast of characters in there and it's
pretty interesting
so i reckon we have a professional
narrator who volunteered his time to do
it
and it's it's really it's quite good
it's it's
i believe i mean as far as other similar
stories i've heard with with prosecutors
trying to pin people like this is their
their careers depend on it and
at the point once you get tangled
entangled in a certain web of lies
what you can't just okay i'll we'll come
clean on this because then you're gonna
you're gonna open up a can of worms to a
whole nother slew of lies
and you're gonna put
politicians or judges jobs at risk their
careers at risk
and they you know they don't want to
ruin their jobs or their careers or
compromise their friends careers
over one kid's life right
yeah this it's so gross it's so
gross it is even the murder for higher
thing i've talked to many people oh yeah
they did that they do
even our lawyer i said thank you but
they don't know proof
and he goes yeah they do that they put
it on there to prejudice people
i've had people say they did it to them
have told me
it's just what they do they smear the
person to make them appear worse
so they can be sure and get i mean it's
really horrible for us
it's become out of control and they when
people
you know they they're arrested and then
they're like well
you better plea and not go to trial
because if you go to trial
you're going to lose which is probable
and um you'll get a worse punishment
so they threaten them they threaten
their families this is what i've been
told
firsthand and so they go okay i'll plead
whatever
even though if i didn't do it and that's
why 98
of people plea make cop a plea
because they're bullied and pressured
and threatened by prosecutors if he
would have basically said i'm guilty of
everything
and would he have been able to take a a
way lesser sentence
say like would he would have would he
have been able to get maybe 10 years he
said up i'm guilty
and and just well 10 years was the
mandatory minimum initially but that
i don't know what that judge would have
done or like it's so hard for me to say
what she would have done i mean
this is not right you should you don't
you don't do
life for that you know it's it's
yeah our country our country's criminal
justice system has been weaponized
against people and it's very alarming
really when you think about it
it's very very concerning and it's
become this mass incarceration that is
huge money giant money all kinds of
people are making money off of it
both privately and and government is
and um it's but the taxpayers are
funding this thing
and it's it's billions of dollars so
it's just
it's horrible how long do you think this
covid lockdown is gonna
go for i don't know i mean i
don't know i i i just it might be quite
a while because before covid you could
visit him in person right
yeah and actually there was a little one
time which was in october this past
month
um that i did get to visit him very
briefly
uh and then they locked him down again
so um
yeah but uh that was the only time i
visited him since march
and um he doesn't you know now there's
no visits
so can you email no he doesn't have
email privileges because it was a
quote-unquote internet crime and he
tried to get the appeal to the bureau of
prisons but they didn't they said no
wow hey listen
a a a national gang leader who could
organize
riots across the country has email but
ross doesn't have email
so tell me how that makes any sense
it doesn't make any sense that's why i
think it's so important for you know
that's why i wanted to have this
conversation with you i think i think
it's super important to
to shine light on things like this and
make more people aware of it and
you know i don't know how i don't know
how else
we could solve this problem but to just
shine more light on it and make more
people aware of it
[Laughter]